what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper Suite a tiff 2022 I've got the
team behind I'm not just saying this
because you're sitting on our couch
right now one of my favorite movies of
this Festival sisu
holy [ __ ] I also have not cursed until
now hold I'm going to embrace it holy
[ __ ] congratulations on what you
accomplished with this movie thank you
very much thank you all right yeah Marie
I'm going to start with you I have a
feeling you've done this a couple of
times but I have to ask you to give a
brief synopsis in case some of our
viewers have no clue what sisu is yet
well uh Cesar is a story about this
old guy who finds a lot of gold in the
Lapland Wilderness and gets to fight
with the Nazis about it
basically no synopsis of this movie
we'll do what I saw Justice
um I was reading about how your dream
was to make a an action movie inspired
by some of your favorite 80s action
movies so can you tell us some of the
biggest Inspirations I know Rambo is one
but are there
I'm first noticing that now so Rambo and
anything else that uh made that list uh
it's pretty hard to get anything else to
that list because Rambo was the biggest
one fair enough fair enough all right so
for each of you when you first get this
script is there anything that your
character goes through that you kind of
like Circle in red and say that is going
to be the toughest thing to pull off and
then ultimately was that the biggest
Challenger did something else Catch You
by surprise when you're filming the
movie
um I mean
the whole shoot
it's like shooting up in the mountains
of Lapland in -20 with 14 mile an hour
winds and snow and dirt and tank noise
and and yammary very kindly made me
shirtless for the first half of the
movie
so you know it was just the whole ordeal
of it
um you know like reading the script for
the first time because there's so little
dialogue throughout
kind of like reading a novella like it
was like reading a short an amazing
short story
um and then to get up there and the Army
is so precise
that everything described in that script
is on screen and it's just incredible
probably because of the lack of dialogue
in the in the script
my little monologue felt like
this is am I doing it right how how will
I pull this off but
I believe you were happy at least it
made it to the film so
from my perspective you nailed it thank
you
for me it was when I when I read the
script the first time
um I couldn't figure out if this movie
is going to be fantastic or [ __ ] because
the the script was so crazy
so I asked my agents to get a
conversation with yamari to see
if I believed him to be the right like
director for this crazy script two
seconds into this conversation I fell in
love with yalmari and and the project
there was no turning back I so wanted to
do it I'd play any part in that movie
just to be a part of the project many
many follow-up questions the first the
first thing I'm going to ask is so you
were concerned when you got the script
and anyone can jump in on this what
about when you hit set because obviously
like nothing ever perfectly goes to plan
so was there ever a day where you were
all like like how is this gonna look
okay on screen but it did no no uh first
of all when I arrived set three days
after they started shooting
um I uh called yamari and I said like
how how do you feel how's it going how
do you feel this is his exact words
I feel like a man
making an historical masterpiece
and that is and that is almari and that
is how
he is and when you come on set he knows
exactly what he wants exactly what he
wants and how he wants it done and made
does not mean that he doesn't like
listen to his actors because he's super
great listener really really good
director but it's inspiring to be a part
of a set where the director has so much
control over his vision and his visuals
and his storytelling and his narrative
so just being a part of obviously like
like Jack is saying it was super harsh
the wind was crazy the cold was
um
quick crazy but just being a part of it
you never ever wondered if this was
gonna be beautiful or spectacular ever
to say that because we'll finish Autumn
will
surprise you and at some point there was
snow
and it wasn't supposed to be snow
so just to to see how the well first of
all yellow made the decisions how we're
going to shoot this and and how the crew
could just adjust to the fact that
wherever we look there's snow and we
can't see the snow and then you don't
see this now at the fair
because they were also Pro so that
wasn't like personal for me but just to
look how they come up quite fast with
huge like solutions that now we have to
we have to film this how are we gonna do
it
and it was it was exciting to to see
like how what what all you came up with
uh you did good
did you ask me something no
it would be magic but that's the stuff
like small
um to follow up on something Axel had
just said about the clarity of your
vision can you tell me like the opposite
version of that where you had Clarity
going into filming a scene but on the
spot you decided that that original
Vision wasn't how you should execute it
and you pivoted on the spot
that almost ever happens like because
if I have a plan how to do it and I know
where I'm gonna do it it usually goes
like it should
but
sometimes of course there's like
location problem like you you just don't
find the location you you need to do
something and that's probably the
biggest luck then I have to change
something to be able to do it somewhere
else I feel like every director on this
planet is going to want your secret
sauce for creating a plan and being able
to execute it perfectly yeah but also I
he's a crazy like he's a problem solver
you I've worked with numerous director
where the producers toss like challenges
right like we can't do that we don't
have enough time we don't have enough
money well we have to move this location
because of this and that there's a
neighbor here screaming we can't be here
or whatever
but you know Martin never complains he
finds the solutions
pretty quick there's a problem solver
that that helps and when that problem is
solved
is often a bit better than what it was
supposed to be right so so it's film is
almost always organic films should be
organic it should be
um it should be a balance between the
ongoing environment what the active
presents and what your Visions are but
when your vision is as clear as your
modest vision is you can always he can
always navigate through it because he
knows exactly what he wants from every
situation every scene so the problem
solving just makes them for us the movie
making
more possible some problems of course
with with the horse no I don't believe
you
the horses actually like that was like
leaving hell with the horses like what
the [ __ ] going all over the place and
and then we have to have some different
ideas how to how to pull it off but that
was crazy what about your dog the dog do
a good job follow the rules
keeps telling us the dog was the best
actor on the car so you know I'm a big
pet lover so I might be you're all
wonderful but I might be partial to the
dog as well
um so you are able to create a plan
execute it and you seem to have a lot of
confidence in your plan but going into
this shoot was there any particular set
piece heavy action heavy Gore that had
you thinking like this might be the most
ambitious and challenging thing I've
come up with here
because I can think of like a laundry
list of ones
we had yeah we had some difficulties
many times but
uh the river scene was quite bad
actually didn't you have to set the
Stunt Man on Fire like far more times
than you probably should have yeah of
course we did it
many times but
that's that's part of the plan
it looks really good I'm I'm obsessed
with like movie Magic what it takes to
do stuff like that and also I love blood
and gore it's a real Artistry and we
never give it enough credit in that
respect so for the three of you is there
anything that you saw happen on this set
that made you go like I cannot believe
that's what it takes to make it look
like that on screen
my favorite moment was when yalmari was
throwing a like a limb it was a foot in
the air and I didn't know there was a
part of the director's job but he did
well and the the shot is in the movie I
feel like limb thrower should be an
actual credit yeah yeah also we were
sitting on top of the tank and it was
the wind was crazy hard and in one like
the first shot with it uh there was a
lot of sand that was blowing in our eyes
so we were like
uh had to clean her eyes after after the
shot and then the second shot came and
the wind was a bit like was was that
hard it was still
and yeah Mario goes where's the smoke
wait there's no smoke that was sand your
money
so where's the sand so he had two people
throw sand in our eyes during a during a
take so me and me I'm supposed to like
look
at your mom while he's walking past and
then I get like I get like sand like in
my eyes it looks good but it's just like
yeah that's how specific He Is We had a
bit of a mantra on set which I take a
little bit of credit for introducing
which was paying his temporary film is
forever
and I think we're all kind of abided by
that I feel like I need that as a tattoo
yeah
yeah but bringing up yorma I
had read somewhere that that was a
little apprehensive to sign on because
of how physical the role was so what
were you able to do for him to make him
feel comfortable jumping into a role
like that
well I
I
promised him that he can wear the jacket
which wasn't the original plan because
it was so windy and cold and my plan was
not to have like a
like a over a jacket
for the other man I still regret it a
little bit
why I think I think he still looks great
but I understand that request it would
have been a big old baby in the cold I
don't know how you are
but he's a tough guy uh
he really is like the all the [ __ ] he
came through on on this film like he was
in really weird places
I can tell I can tell but you're almost
different though you have to tell what
just I would just I saw about the ADR
normal people like normal actors coming
to ADR we put on the mic we have the mic
in front of us we have the script and we
we do the ADR but what does your mother
what does he bring into the into the ADR
Studio because it was like five hour him
breathing to the microphone and he was I
need something heavy I need something
heavy on the recorded guy was like
what's heavy something heavy bring me
something heavy and they find this a big
piece of asphalt and he was like doing
this the whole day
five hours
I respect this great I respect anyone on
this planet actor or any other field who
can do ad r that just boggles my brain I
want to highlight each of your
characters now Jack I'll start with you
what was it like Phil figuring out the
right dine like the power Dynamic to be
like the right hand to to Bruno just in
terms of how they operate
um I've got to be honest I'm not sure I
actually gave it too much forethought
before getting there but me and axel
flew in together and we had a couple
nights like making our way up through
the Wilderness before we actually made
it set so we kind of organically formed
like a bit of a bond anyway so so by day
one it kind of just fell into place
there was definitely some unspoken
history that that I thought I could like
it was business as usual for them and I
loved how that came through but without
explanation yeah I guess I guess just
the fact that we'd already been on a
journey through the Wilderness before we
even got to set sort of already cemented
a bond there you feel that I mean Mimosa
something similar for you you like we
don't necessarily know precisely what
she has gone through but we can feel it
in the way she carries herself and
through her performance in general so
what kind of I don't know if you want to
like spell out a backstory but what
specific quality of hers did you always
know you had to hold tight to in order
to keep her consistent and represent
some of that history
I was happy that
it's kind of the we talked about the
Dynamics with the with the girls in the
in the trunk and obviously I know it's
from the beginning like
tough cookie maybe the toughest of them
but I know I mean
I'm finished I know the word Cecil it
was kind of I was taking
I was taking a little seesaw with Aina
from start start to to end even if it's
um
yeah I think that's it that's
as it's explained it's impossible to
translate but that was something that I
could read right from the title this is
what we're gonna need also to to minus
character not not only Artemis can 100
feel that in her as well Axel I I don't
want to obviously spoil anything but one
thing I'm very curious about ultimately
in the end if he could go back to the
beginning and make a different decision
in terms of going after him do you think
he would or do you think he was doomed
to go down that path no matter what or
lead his men down that path I think I
think he's doomed to go down that path
uh obviously he would have changed some
some ways but
I think he is an alpha alpha male that
will never ever
feel the defeat even if he loses you
know like he is the kind of man that
won't
um accept the loss so I think he would
go back and just try it again just see
if he could go again he will he would
lose again but I don't think he has the
necessary insight to
overlook and oversee what what atomy is
and and and how what sisu is so in
conclusion you should turn this into a
Time Loop movie and we can see a
different variation with every
installment yeah I had so much trouble
of uh figuring out how Adam actually
will kill all these Nazis that I
couldn't do it again
I feel like you've probably been asked
this a million times and it hurts me
that I'm gonna have to ask you but did
you ever think of what he might want to
do with that gold
yeah that that was my biggest challenge
when I was writing like like how can I
end this what what Adam would do
because I somehow knew that he won't be
any happier with the gold or uh because
he's a man who likes to do stuff and if
you get that amount of money and like
it's not going to be a happy end and
then I realized that we have to stop the
film
into the bank so
but I gave it a lot of thought and and I
think he would be like so badly I'll
call it how do you say it alcoholism
alcoholic alcoholic and spending
somewhere in a hotel of Las Palmas or
something and being really sad dude my
heart like a Nick Cage live in Las Vegas
just yeah just drinking himself to death
have any of you ever come up with like
creative endings for him to the movie no
but we were talking about it because I
think
I mean at the end of the day the the uh
the story is not about the gold the
story is about
um the gold starts it it's it's about a
man working for something for a very
long time hard to get it and somebody
steals it and he doesn't they don't they
don't steal even they don't steal his
goal they steal his dignity the steal
his pride and and so this the object is
gold but the theme of the film I feel is
about Humanity it's about
um self-respect it's about revenge it's
about dignity uh and it's about pride
and it's about
um
and blowing up Nazis and blowing up
Nazis but it's it's at the at the end of
the day we were talking about it I think
Bruno and and uh atami would use the
money and the goals for the same thing
and it will it would give them both
misery
because the the like like yamari says
the the answer is doesn't lay in the
goal that's not the answer the answer is
surviving right
I don't know what this says about me
just like YouTube for hopeful things but
I'm like like what you just described
about him is right but he's going to use
the gold to like fight for other people
to preserve that and them to me that
might be that might be that might be
desperately reaching for Silver Linings
always I have to let you all go thank
you so much for the movie thank you for
coming can I just please can I just
please
thank you for really good questions and
an enormous insight and and and a love
for cinematics inspiring and clear thank
you so much thank you this clip forever
it means a lot that you said that thank
you to everybody out there thanks for
watching this uh interview do not forget
to look out for sisu trust me it's
excellent we'll see you soon